well one way we can do that of course is
if we can turn off our sprinklers get a
little bit of rain so we're still in
monsoon season ted's going to talk about
chances of rain but also our perseid
media shower yeah this actually was sent
to us by tyler levitt he always sends us
some great picks right went out early
morning and i got this great shot of the
the meteor showers look at that and the
fact it peaks overnight so after
midnight your best chance to check it
out you don't need binoculars and you
don't need a telescope you just need the
trained eye and away from all the lights
in las vegas should be a nice sight to
see
103 are high for the day today they put
us right near average 83 overnight for
the low the record on the state 115 now
set way back in 1937. new neighborhoods
here to show you again centennial hills
103. somewhere here at 96 right now
currently 100 even for the lakes 102
downtown and north las vegas sunrise
mountain 103.
same for green valley seven hills 102
for you in henderson right now roads
ranch and mountains edge coming in right
at the century mark outside the valley's
still hot for you too with humidity up
to 20 percent 102 for prompt 101 for
boulder city lofland also at 102 degrees
at this hour radar image does show those
clouds if you look outside you see the
clouds over the sheep range and the
spring mountains those are isolated
thunderstorms they fizzled out
short-lived not lasting too long but the
big storms right now are way up in
lincoln county one flash flood warning
in effect right now south of cali india
in effect until 7 45 here's a look at
those storms right now the ones over
here are dying out but these ones here
from cali any moving downward still
holding together we'll see if any of
those reach us in fact futurecast does
show slight chances of an isolated
thunderstorm early on the evening we'll
see if that is possible we know the
better chances will be in the higher
terrain
but we'll keep it in our chances for
this evening but by the time we get late
night tonight it'll all start to clear
around so here's your forecast tonight
84 degrees partly cloudy skies isolated
thunderstorms are a slight possibility
for the early evening hours maybe after
sundown and then tomorrow 105 hazy and
humid unfortunately non-thunderstorms
are still a possibility for tomorrow
mainly the mountains favoring the higher
terrain but then by the time we get to
next week that of course is going to
change 103 tomorrow for centennial hills
same for mountains edge 104 sandy valley
four to our spring valley fort in
washington north las vegas 104 107 for
green valley along with sunrise mountain
now keep in mind it's going to be hot
tomorrow we're also going to keep around
a little bit of humidity too 102 for
tomorrow 103 boulder city lothan you'll
check in at 111 by tomorrow afternoon
here's your eight day forecast most of
the storms will be in the mountains for
these next few days leading into your
weekend but it's going to get hot keep
around the humidity better chance for
storms now will return maybe monday
night and through the week next week
numbers will drop but get right back up
again by thursday near the century mark
that is your most accurate forecast here
on eight news now